uh host author of the upcoming book
Serenity in the storm living through
chaos by Leading on Christ Kaylee
mcinany is with us uh also the host of
the Monica Crowley podcast our friend
Monica Crowley and our other friend who
would be a great host of a media show
right here on the Fox News channel uh
Joe Concha is with us good to see you
all thank you
I'll you can decide if you want to
respond to the craziness of Weingart and
that's fine or Lori lightweight losing
is pretty big news Well I could tell you
why I need to take that one because I
stood at the podium in the white house
and I called out Chicago's crime because
in the Trump White House we cared about
the victims of crime she responded and
called me a Karen so she had enough time
to call out the White House Press
Secretary as a Karen rather than
focusing on crime in her City so I loved
her dance moves that was fun to watch on
Tick Tock although they really weren't
they weren't good
um but sorry Karen here you lost uh ouch
all right Monica well you know what's
amazing is that people in deep blue
areas like New York or Chicago Seattle
San Francisco they will constantly vote
blue and they will put up with a lot
high crime high taxes low quality of
life until the moment that they don't
and every once in a while in these blue
States and Blue urban areas they will
hit a wall and what we're seeing in
Chicago tonight is that the people of
Chicago have hit a wall and they have
said enough now ultimately we have to
see who is going to be the mayor I hope
it's not another insane left Winger it's
not going to be much of an improvement
but it is amazing that you can see this
kind of progress in a place like Chicago
hometown of Barack Obama now is going to
reach for a different mayor you are not
a fan of Randy weigarden I'm going to
put on the parent hat for a moment here
Sean okay Mike Pompeo said not too long
ago that Randy Weingarten is the most
dangerous person in the world I'm like
all right and the world's a little thick
right I mean you got Vladimir Putin Kim
Jong-un uh you got Prince Harry and
Meghan Markle I mean these are dangerous
people right but as a parent who saw his
kids young kids right kindergarten Pre-K
out of school for so many months after
the science and the data said it was
perfectly safe to be back in school and
the impact we've seen on children now in
our educational system in general to
hear her go completely Loco like she was
on pixie sticks and Red Bull over at the
Supreme Court right now which I take in
the morning by the way Joe Biden could
use a little whatever she's eating yes
yes this is true I'll have what she's
having student loan forgiveness is a
sham right because you look at it 50 of
the loans go to those with graduate
degrees those are doctors those are
lawyers these are the people like my
wife an ER Doctor Who over years can pay
back the loan is my wife getting a
retroactive check by the way how's this
going to work exactly it's not going to
why should anybody why should anybody
that works hard in this audience have to
pay they pay for their own College I pay
for my own College until I ran out of
money and dropped out I didn't have the
money to finish yeah and then I paid
back my student loan why should anyone
else pay for someone else's education
they shouldn't it's not only unjust and
that's common sense it's also
unconstitutional Joe Biden said this
Nancy Pelosi said this Obama's former
Council for the Department of Education
wrote this in a memo obtained by The
Wall Street Journal no one should have
to do that but this woman this lunatic
Randy Weingarten was the one who Terry
McAuliffe thought she he could bring out
and win that race in Virginia it failed
miserably so keep playing your Clips we
only got 20 seconds now if we paid for
Monica Crowley schooling I think she has
15 degrees so we'd be broke as a country
cartel
villagers and all of the damage that is
done to America's children our Great
American panel thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else